on les faubourgs de kiev les immeubles
porte encore les stigmates des
affrontements
l'armée russe a quitté hier pin il y a
déjà deux mois les danses et dru
l'ancienne ligne de front le temps s'est
arrêté
nadia qui venait à 80 en marche dans les
ruines de sa maison
mon lit était ici il était ici et là
c'était le placard et moi je dormais là
il ne reste plus que le garage
des bénévoles réparé le toit parce que
c'est là dorénavant qu'elle va habiter
bogdan travailler dans un label de
musique avant la guerre nous devrions
d'abord réparer le mur non nous devons
d'abord le faire d'une manière
différente nous pouvons le maître ici
ensuite le construire aujourd'hui il
fait partie d'un groupe de volontaires
civils qui sécurise et reconstruisent
les maisons
les volontaires se sont juste organiser
ensemble pour chercher des choses à
faire pour être utile après la guerre
on doit être utile pour son pays et pour
son peuple on peut pas rester assis à
regarder
au rez de chaussée nadia préparent le
déjeuner elle se confie sur la mort de
son fils un civil de 53 ans tué au début
de la guerre
je pleure tout le temps
je me fiche des destructions de ma
maison
je pleure mon fils
comme la maison de nadia la moitié de la
ville d'hier pin a été détruite à
quelques centaines de mètres de là butch
a ici pour le retour de ses habitants la
municipalité aménage des mobile homes 88
familles seront bientôt hébergés ici
presque réfugiés dans leur propre ville